welcome to this webinar series
introducing Mathematica eleven I'm John
McLean I work a technical strategy at
Wolfram research and I've been at
Wolfram since the days of Mathematica
2.0 so it's a great pleasure to be the
one to introduce you to Mathematica 11
the 19th release that I've been involved
with with over 500 new functions and a
huge number of improvements to existing
functions there's more to Mathematica 11
than I can possibly tell you in this
webinar so I'm just going to give you a
quick overview and find share with you
our vision that this release takes is
one step closer towards afterwards stick
around for other sessions that will go
into more depth I will try and answer as
many of your questions as possible at
the end of this session but if you ask
them during the session through the chat
window at the side of the screen then we
have experts on hand who will also kline
answer them let me start by reminding of
the ambitious goal of the mathematic
system we're trying to build a single
integrated system that seamlessly
combines all of technical computing so
while it's sometimes helpful to look at
Mathematica from the viewpoints of a
particular field of computation it's
vital to the design of Mathematica that
functionality is not ring-fenced into
discrete toolboxes but is coherently
unified to give you an uninterrupted
workflow and to give you a common
language to exchange technical ideas
with colleagues with different
computational needs nevertheless one
perspective from which a lot of people
view Mathematica is from the world of
data science and one of the most
exciting fields in data science at the
moment is machine learning
here is a typical application using
computer vision the client recognized
image contents as they held up the
object you can see underneath
Mathematica is best guess as to what
it's seeing
article 11 now recognizes over 10,000
different objects and you can see on the
whole it does a pretty good job of
recognizing what it sees
now version 11 extends that improves
these capabilities with new functions
for clustering data reducing
dimensionality and extracting features
machine learning functions also now
accept a wider range of data types the
version 10 release series made machine
learning accessible to those without
data science backgrounds but Mathematica
11 extends those capabilities to the
expert user too by exposing a complete
symbolic framework for building custom
neural networks a full complement of
vision oriented lasers included as well
as encoders and decoders to make
training vision networks interoperate
seamlessly with the rest of the language
so you can now train your own image
identifier but here I just have a simple
text sentiment analyzer the neural
network that you see here took just a
few lines of code to specify if I ask it
to retrain that neural network you'll
see that the arrow gradually reduces as
the network is trained to my data set
training now supports GPU acceleration
and sadly I don't have one on this
laptop making it feasible to train
networks on big data sets using standard
hardware so whether you're classifying
fuzzy data making predictions or
extracting important features from
complex data mathematical machine
learning is accessible to beginners and
experts alike of course data science
isn't just about machine learning and
we've added extensive functionality for
handling many different specific kinds
of data text processing has been
extended with more tools for cleaning
text and for extracting structured
information and semantic meaning from
words and sentences here you can see the
sentence structure being calculated as I
type Mathematica 11 also extends support
for a large range of non-english
languages and character sets
another key datatype is sound and we've
developed a completely new audio
framework audio data is now effectively
a first class object in Mathematica
there's a whole collection of new local
and global audio measurements and new
filters and all of your effects have
been added the new audio object is
capable of representing multi-channel
sound in memory out of core and
streaming of course one area where
Mathematica is already very strong is
image processing but there are lots of
new capabilities here too there is
better support for processing and
viewing out of Cori matures
significantly extended image
highlighting and much better color
support text recognition makes use of
the improvements to international
character sets and word data that I
already mentioned so that it now
supports 60 different languages there
are new capabilities for image alignment
and measuring content displacement
between sequences of images I'm using
image displacement measurement here to
overlay a vector diagram which indicates
the average flow through this video
sequence as the general image processing
functionality has become bored enough
it's been possible for us to start
extending it into different image
processing application areas Mathematica
Levin supports for example new
computational photography capabilities
such as combining multiple exposure
images and then tone mapping the
resulting HDR image white balance
controls in color temperature
adjustments have also been enhanced for
photography and in the field of
microscopy image processing we've added
focus compositing this example obviously
isn't from a microscope but it exhibits
a common microscopy issue the depth of
field is too shallow to get everything
in focus at once however if we combine
all of the different images with their
different focus distances we can create
a single image with a very high depth of
field everything's in focus at once as I
said at the start it's important that
functionality joins up so let's take a
look at an image there might simply be
the first step towards a bigger
computation
here's satellite imagery of the Great
Salt Lake now there's lots you can do
with pixel data but there's lots of
things where it isn't the best
representation so massacre 11 has
introduced capabilities for
automatically converting images into
computable geometric objects this is the
triangulated mesh representation of the
region and 3d images say from an MRI
scan can also be converted to 3d
geometry meshes of course mathematics
geometry framework has also been
extended there are new ways to specify
regions from arrays and meshes or by
using new special region constructs
there are fast ways to compute simple
bounding regions and there's also a
bunch of new properties that can be
calculated from any kind of region for
example I can take this simple model the
Space Shuttle I can calculate its
moments of inertia directly but one area
where there have been dramatic
improvements is to create a complete
seamless workflow through to 3d printing
you can now print essentially any 3d
plot or geometric object directly to
your 3d printer and if you don't have a
3d printer well that doesn't matter as
Mathematica also integrates into a range
of third-party online printing services
this tall I made let's me paste a simple
2d logo and using image mesh function
that I showed you before it creates a 3d
solid version but when I click this
button it calls on the in this case
sculpt tio online service uploads my
object and then after I've confirmed the
size and color of materials I just pay
them and my object gets sent to me in
the post
to make sure that 3d printing works
there are also new tools for mesh defect
detection mesh repair and for resizing
and aligning objects we can even hollow
out solid objects for you to save on
print toner geometry isn't all about
abstract shapes or creating nice
printable objects though it's a
fundamental way of describing real-world
objects and spaces ready for computation
all kinds of computations in Mathematica
understand regions as input
specifications from integration to
optimization so let's take a look at
that Lake region that we looked at a
minute ago and compute with it we could
for example study how the wave equation
behaves on this lake and we've got a new
tool in that toolkit two new methods for
finding eigenvalues for differential
operators over regions allow us to see
the different oscillation modes of this
lake or we could create an interesting
initial perturbation and solve the
partial differential equation to see how
the waves would travel around this
region over time that's a 2d geometric
region but of course we can do the same
thing in 3d for example here using some
imported CAD data we can see an
exaggerated visualization of the fifth
eigenfunction of this engine camshaft
other maths improvements include support
for integral equations dramatic
improvements in solving symbolic partial
differential equations and a slew of new
number theory functions being able to
easily compute ever more complex results
puts more pressure on the ability to
visualize them so Mathematica 11 has
added a whole collection of new 4d
visualization capabilities which are
able to show contours densities or
vectors over any combination of 3d
slices or 3d geometric region surfaces
there's also a new 4d transparent
density plot function the leverages
Mathematica is built in 3d image
rendering capabilities even very basic
plotting routines continue to improve
with better automatic discontinuity
detection to give you more accurate
plots with less work the graph
visualization is now included in the
visual themes framework making it easier
to produce professional-looking visuals
as Mathematica is built in real world
increases it also becomes more important
to add domain-specific visualizations to
make sense of the data this for example
uses the new Anatomy plot function to
generate a customized 3d representation
of the human body and of course if we
wanted to we could send this to a 3d
printer the geometry of the human body
is just one property of the new Anatomy
knowledge base other new sets of
computable data that have been included
in the wulfing knowledgebase include
food and nutrition data geo
gravitational and geomagnetic data human
growth and mortality data and lots of
others as well as adding lots more data
to the knowledgebase the infrastructure
underneath it has been upgraded so you
can now more efficiently query and
aggregate data and for the first time
you can also extend the knowledge base
with your own entities and data so that
you can access it all in the same
unified way one basic but very key
feature of the knowledge base is support
for units and it supports a huge number
of units but just like every other part
of Mathematica that makes sense
units have to work seamlessly with other
functionality and mathematical xi has
extended support for this greatly units
are now supported throughout statistics
functionality backed by a new efficient
structure for unit based arrays of data
now this is especially impressive when
you consider the huge scope of
mathematical statistics for example by
version 8 Mathematica had the largest
collection of probability distributions
of any system available ahead of
statistics focus packages like SAS and R
of course it doesn't have that record
anymore because mathematical 11 has
added a large collection of matrix
distributions putting it even further
ahead of other systems and of course
like all the other distributions these
new ones support all of the key
statistics functionality such as random
number generation parameter estimation
hypothesis testing and transformations
into custom distributions
aside from coverage lots of work goes
into making mathematical statistics more
reliable in difficult situations without
you having to intervene and so
mathematical 11 improves sampling from
discontinuous and singular distributions
and applies more automatic
simplifications to derive distributions
as well as better connectivity with
units statistics is also better
connected to geometry with the addition
of support for uniform random sampling
from geometric regions of any
dimensionality and also converting from
data to regions has also been improved
with new fast computations of bounding
regions making sure that computations
can be combined seamlessly is a design
obsession Wolfram one domain that
typifies the joined up nature of
Mathematica is geo computation it brings
together the knowledge base with
information on cities countries terrain
mountains lakes and the rest together
with mathematical projections custom
visualizations and computational
analysis all of these aspects of geo
computation have been enhanced the
knowledge base has been extended with
historical country borders much more
polygon data including administrative
subdivisions of countries here for
example I've created an animation of the
growth of the Roman Empire there are 100
new projections giving Mathematica the
most complete such collection of any
computational system now just think
about that for a moment Mathematica only
took on geovisualization in version 10
less than two years ago and already it
is a past dedicated applications that's
because our developers just like you
have the entire technology stack of
Mathematica to call on when they develop
new functionality it's a real testament
to the power of integrated computation
in an all-in-one system you can develop
so much so fast
visualization has been extended with new
geo density plot interactively' zoom and
palpable maps and their satellite
backgrounds now for not only earth but
also the moon and other planets and
finally computation has been enhanced
with new geo histograms fast and
accurate area calculations and the
ability to calculate road travel
directions here for example are the best
routes to Champaign Illinois from every
major US city of course computation is
only a path of the story of Mathematica
the wulfing language lets you develop
applications for deployment to other
people from one line apps using
Mathematica is amazing manipulate
command for millions of lines of whorfin
code
and make web services like wolf malphur
possible so naturally there are plenty
of improvements to the development and
deployment capabilities but the central
story for development is the same as it
is for computation we want desktop cloud
and device development to join up just
as seamlessly as computations you might
once
deploy anywhere so the wolf entailed has
been updated to version 11 of the
Wolfram language so that everything you
can compute on the desktop can be
deployed to the cloud whether that's a
former minute plays an interactive
document for human use using only a
browser or to a cloud-based API for a
computer program to access a new version
of the CDF player will let you share
interactive documents for offline use
and a Raspberry Pi version will allow
you to run the Wolfram language on
embedded or autonomous devices in the
cloud there are rich ways to specify 12
or moved automatic report generation and
a new framework for sequencing questions
from users in multi-page forms but as
well as improved interface building the
software development toolkit has also
been extended with new tools for storing
data in the cloud network programming
cryptography asynchronous messaging
between applications and other system
level programming tools new versions of
Mathematica are not just about adding
new capabilities though algorithmic
advances give us a regular opportunities
just to make existing functionality
better as well as some improvements to
robustness in the face of pathological
problems some of which I've already
mentioned there are constant efforts to
improve speed performance to some of the
most notable improvements can be found
in image processing geometry and graph
calculations where several algorithms
are now many times faster Mathematica 11
is not just the most capable version of
Mathematica ever it's also the fastest
execution speed though is only part of
the equation it's also vital to improve
the development speed as the breadth of
Mathematica grows it becomes ever more
important that we can continue to
improve the ease of use of the system
after what's the point in fast
computation if it takes you a long time
to instruct the computer central to
ease-of-use is our focus on automation
making sure that algorithm choice
parameter choices and handling of
difficult corner cases are all automate
it remains a key design aim and the key
differentiator against more traditional
computation systems let me show you a
really simple example Mathematica 11
spots discontinuities in this plot and
it doesn't join up the different
sections now I could have specified
those brakes brakes myself in previous
releases which was a minor waste of my
time but more importantly if I was a
first student or this was a more complex
example I might not know that there was
an issue there to fix and joining the
plot over the discontinuities might
confuse me or mislead me Mathematica is
full of such automation but unfortunate
I don't have time to talk about it
instead I'll just highlight some nice
interface improvements there are now
more cases where Mathematica will offer
you contextually relevant Auto
completion making it easier than ever to
find the right command and to save you a
little bit of typing improved code
tooltips now hope you're to read Wolfram
language code in 12 different languages
here you can see hints as to what this
code means in Russian and they appear
automatically as you type likewise
spell-checking has been extended to 25
languages and includes collections of
technical terms and it also happens in
real time error messages now let you
immediately see a stack trace of where
the error occurred so for example I can
see the source of the error in this
badly written function is another
function I've written called my internal
function being called with a value of 0
everyone's use of Mathematica is
different but with enhancements to many
of its key domains of use the inclusion
of new computation domains improvements
to robustness performance and ease of
use there is something for almost every
existing Mathematica user and hundreds
of fresh reasons to reconsider
Mathematica if you or your colleagues
are not already part of the family so
please set some time aside to look at
the full summary of new features on the
website and do hang around now for some
of the more in-depth talks to us and
follow but before that I'd be happy to
try and take some of your questions
thank you